because of this latest shooting in san
jose the conversation in the capitol is
once again focused on what can be
done at the national level to prevent
this type of gun violence
senators in washington were
questioning david chapman who is
nominated to be  The director of the
Department of Alcohol, Tobacco and
Firearms when they received news
Wednesday of the San Jose shooting that
killed nine victims,
was asked by California Senator Diane Feinstein
what he would do if he is confirmed
as director.  who said that the agency would be
dedicated to investigating crimes but
also to preventing them the murderer in
sanjosé used pistols that are legal
in california according to authorities in
washington in recent years the debate
on how to prevent this type of
shooting has focused on renewing the
ban  federal assault rifles
Republicans are against such
measures and  until now they have prevented
them from becoming law again some
activists like the brady group say that
currently the laws that already exist on the
purchase and sale of weapons are not
respected because for years the
department of alcohol, tobacco and
firearms has not  currently had a fixed boss
the senate is considering
approving the crime as the head of the
chepén agency could be the first to
be approved by the senate in more than
six years reporting in washington
alexandra limón